[Musica]
Oh Barbie oggi sei stupenda anche se tu
lo sei sempre grazie Ken Ti amo alla
follia la mia vita non è niente senza di
te Che carino grazie Oh guarda andiamo a
raccogliere i frutti di bosco in quella
cascata laggiù Sì
sì Che bello stare insieme Sì hai
[Musica]
ragione
Oh mia
Barbie tranquilla Il mio amore per te ti
guarirà Che bella atmosfera io e te
soli Sì sì è proprio bella Barbie Senti
volevo confessarti i miei sentimenti io
provo qualcosa di molto forte per te
Barbie Io ti
amo
Ciao io sono Barbie stramba Barbie Ti
piace il mio trucco Wow che bello molto
colorato ma proprio adesso dovevi venire
sì e ci sono anche i miei amici Ciao
Barbie Ciao Ken Ciao Barbie Ciao Ken
Ciao Barbie Ciao Barbie Ciao Barbie Ciao
Ken Ciao ciao barb cia ciao barb C Ciao
Ken Ciao ciao Ken Ciao Ken Ciao Ciao
Barbie Ciao Barbie Io mi allontano un
attimo Ho bisogno di un po' di tempo per
me come stai Barbie tutto bene tu Bene
bene e come stai Ken tutto bene Tu come
stai Barbie Bene bene e tu Barbie Io
tutto bene Ken e tu Ken io Benissimo Ehi
ma aspettate un attimo dov'è andato Ken
andiamo a chiamarlo Sì così facciamo
passeggiata Sì andiamo a fare una
passeggiata Ken
Ken sarebbe stata la mia occasione per
baciare Barbie una volta per tutte io le
ho confidato quello che prova invece
sono arrivati Ken e poi è arrivato Ken è
arrivato anche Ken e Barbie c'era già è
arrivata anche Barbie e magari sarebbe
arrivata anche un'altra Barbie ho perso
la mia occasione per
baciarla come
farò Chissà perché Ken è voluto
andarsene
[Musica]
via Eccolo quello è Ken Ken Dai andiamo
Sì Ken Ken Ciao Cosa è successo niente
tutto a posto Ah bene bene Adesso puoi
tornare a giocare con noi Ma sì dai
andiamo da Barbie andiamo a divertirci
dai Ma dov'è finito Barbie Sono qui
Barbie stereotipo la mia Barbie è
sparita ma non c'è più presto presto
andiamo a cercarla
Barbie nuovo mistero da risolvere Barbie
è sparita è stata rapita Chi sarà stato
tra loro lo scopriremo assieme e anche
voi Provate a risolvere questo mistero
assieme a noi proprio come nel mio nuovo
libro la città stregata che è ora
disponibile on e in tutte le librerie in
questo libro Anche voi vi trasformerete
in investigatori del mistero come me
Vitale ma ora prima di iniziare gli
interrogatori dei nostri sospettati
andiamo a vedere la scena del delitto
Dove è sparita Barbie Pronti Via Ditemi
esattamente dove è sparita Barbie Dov'è
l'ultima volta che l'avete vista
l'abbiamo vista proprio lì guarda lì lì
lì ok vado subito a controllare ma voi
restate qua perché non dovete sporcare
la scena del crimine con le vostre
impronte
digitali Ecco Barbie è sparita
qua di chi sarà questa giacca di Barbie
o di Ken Il libro Mi sta comunicando
Qualcosa deve esseri un indizio
qua Un guanto questo è sicuramente il
guanto del rapitore di Barbie abbiamo
trovato il nostro primo
indizio e ora è il momento
dell'interrogatorio interroghiamo i
nostri sospettati e la mia domanda per
voi è avete mai litigato con Barbie no
Che domande non ho mai litigato con
Barbie Io la amo anzi forse una volta
ecco Ma più che litigato ci sono rimasto
male perché eravamo una sfida di danza e
stavamo ballando io e lei insieme come
sempre perché siamo sempre
[Musica]
insieme e a un certo punto lei non ha
più voluto ballare con me Io volevo
ballare vicino a lei e mi ha scansato G
ha mandato da un'altra parte e ci sono
rimasto malissimo La mia amata Barbie
che non ha voluto ballare con me Ma
com'è possibile
No beh non ho litigato con Barbie però
ho litigato con Ken per colpa di Barbie
c'era la gara di forza per vedere chi
era l'uomo più forte di Barbie
Aho distruggo
Ken Sfidami se hai il
[Musica]
coraggio
e stavo per vincere io quando ad un
certo punto ciao Ken Barbie passò
davanti a me mi salutò e io mi sono
distratto Ciao
Barbie e quindi l'altro Ken ha avuto
l'opportunità di dare il colpo decisivo
e alla fine lei se n'è andata con lui e
io ci sono rimasto molto male non è
giusto volevo andare io a fare la
passeggiata con Barbie Però al massimo
avrei fatto sparire Ken non Barbie
litigato con Barbie No non ho mai
litigato con Barbie anche se una volta
le ho preparato un piatto uno dei miei
piatti speciali preparato con molta
cura cos'è E lei prontamente lo ha solo
annusato guardato con schifo e se n'è
andata Beh io ci sono rimasto un po'
male ma non troppo perché alla fine l'ho
mangiato io Beh io non ho litigato con
Barbie però Certo è sempre lei al centro
dell'attenzione a tutti i concorsi di
bellezza vince sempre
lei
e non lascia la possibilità a noi Barbie
diverse e originali di brillare noi
sappiamo fare tante cose e lei non ci dà
la possibilità di farci vedere però non
sono stata io a rapirla Io sono Barbie
stramba mica Barbie criminale ora che
abbiamo ascoltato le loro storie è
arrivato il momento di fare la nostra
accusa ma prima di fare l'accusa
prendete il libro e apritelo
all'alfabeto segreto traducete questa
parola perché è un indizio per scoprire
chi è il colpevole e secondo voi chi è
il colpevole avete analizzato bene tutto
il video andiamo subito ad accusare i
nostri sospettati partiamo da te
Ken io ma non sono stato io e infatti tu
Ken Non potresti mai rapire Barbie Tu
pensi solo a mangiare L'unica cosa che
potresti rapire una
pizza Ma come fa a sapere che ho rapito
una
[Musica]
pizza Quindi tu Ken
Sei
innocente passiamo ora al prossimo
sospettato e cioè tu che com'è possibile
non posso essere stato io io non odio
Barbie Io odio Ken al massimo avrei
rapito lui E infatti tu sei in realtà
segretamente innamorato di Barbie è per
quello che durante il tuo racconto
dicevi che cercavi di attirare la sua
attenzione nella sfida di forza e volevi
battere Ken Quindi al massimo avresti
potuto rapire Ken non Barbie Quindi non
sei stato tu tu Sei innocente esatto
vedi magari un giorno ci penserò a
rapire Ken cosa sarai il prossimo a
essere arrestato Allora ma ora passiamo
al prossimo sospettato e cioè tu
Ken io ma io amo Barbie Anzi
sbrighiamoci perché all follia Non so
perché ma non credo davvero nel tuo
amore verso Barbie sembra che nascondi
qualcosa però dai tuoi racconti ho
capito che tu ci tieni davvero a lei
quindi non avresti mai potuto rapirla
perché le vuoi davvero bene e quindi Sei
innocente anche tu sì Sono innocente Non
avrei mai potuto rapire l'amore della
mia vita ma non dubitate mai più del mio
amore verso di lei è tutto ciò che amo
davvero bene adesso rimane solo un
sospettato o meglio sospettata e cioè tu
Barbie
stramba sei stata tu fin da quando
eravate piccole Barbie stereotipo ti ha
sempre oscurata non è così Ma certo È
vero però non avrei mai potuto rapire
Barbie Insomma è la Barbie più
importante di Barbie Land Ed è proprio
per questo che l'hai fatta sparire
contest di bellezza bambole e ora pure
la Barbie più importante di Barbie Land
tu non potevi sopportare questo tu
volevi che le attenzioni andassero anche
alle Barbie diverse alle Barbie strambe
le Barbie diverse da Barbie stereotipo
ed è per questo che l'hai rapita
confessa sei stata tu anche se fossi
stata io non hai le prove perciò non
puoi fare niente Ti sbagli che non ho le
prove questo l'ho trovato nella scena
del delitto Dove è sparita Barbie e
quindi potrebbe essere di chiunque
perché per forza mio ed è qua che ti
sbagli perché questo pomeriggio ho
mandato il mio aiutante investigatore
Ken Vitale a perquisire la tua stanza e
guarda che cosa ha trovato un altro
guanto uguale sei stata tu a rapire
Barbie confessa E va bene confesso sono
stata io come avete capito Non ne potevo
più di Barbie stereotipo Insomma è da
tutte le parti nelle bambole nei film
nei vestiti sei una Ina pensa a Barbie
pensa solo a lei bionda È perfetta E
invece a noi Barbie diverse non ci pensa
nessuno L'unico modo era farla sparire
lo sapevo come Ti sei permessa a far
sparire la mia
fidanzata farla sparire non era la
soluzione giusta Io capisco che anche
voi Barbie diverse dovete avere la
vostra importanza e questo è giusto Ma
dovevate parlarne assieme a tutte le
altre Barbie e My Ken rapirla non è la
soluzione ma adesso per farti perdonare
di dici dove l'hai nascosta Ecco Barbie
Barbie Tranquilla amore mio ti salverò
io spostati un po' perfetto
Arrivo forza
andiamo Barbie Scusami tanto se ti ho
rapita Ma io volevo solamente che noi
Barbie strambe avessimo più
importanza Ah giusto ti devo slegare
amore
mio ecco qua
Mi dispiace che tu non ti sia sentita
accettata per ora pirmi non è stata la
soluzione parleremo con tutti Ken e con
tutte le Barbie e faremo in modo che
anche voi Barbie diverse possiate essere
protagoniste qui a Barbie quanto la
amo sì magari Barbie Land diventerà
stamby Land e un altro caso è stato
risolto il caso è chiuso e se voi volete
continuare a risolvere dei casi
misteriosi con noi Mi raccomando andate
subito a prendere il libro La città
stregata e ora è disponibile onl e in
libreria e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video
[Musica]
Ciao